This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantum. On a September evening in 2016, Terence Croucher's SUV stopped in the middle of a road in Tulsa, Oklahoma. A woman saw him step out of the car. The doors of the car were open, the engine was still running. The woman called 911. Officer Betty Shelby was on her way to an unrelated incident when the call came in. Terrence was 40, African-American, born and raised in Tulsa.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2016年9月的一个晚上，特伦斯·克劳彻的SUV停在俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨市的一条马路中间。一名女子看到他下车。车门开着，发动机还在运转。这名女子拨打了911。警官贝蒂·谢尔比在前往处理另一起无关事件的途中接到了这个报警电话。特伦斯40岁，非洲裔美国人，在塔尔萨出生并长大。
He was a church-going man with four children. Betty was 42, white, a mother. She was born in a small town not far from Tulsa. In an ideal world, these two Oklahoma natives, close an age, ought to have had more to bring them together than hold them apart. But on this evening, there was no small talk or friendly chatter. The police officer told Terrence to take his hands out of his pockets. According to our attorney, he forced complied.
他是一个经常去教堂的人，有四个孩子。贝蒂42岁，白人，是一位母亲。她出生于离塔尔萨不远的一个小镇。在理想的世界里，这两个俄克拉荷马州本地人年龄相仿，本该有更多的共同点将他们凝聚在一起，而不是将他们分离开来。但在今晚，没有闲聊，也没有友善的交谈。警察告诉特伦斯把手从口袋里拿出来。根据我们的律师所说，他被迫遵从了。
He then put his hands up in the air. Moments later, he put his hands back in his pockets. By this point, multiple police officers had gathered and drawn their guns and tasers. Overhead, the police chopper filmed events as they unfolded. From the video, it's hard to tell exactly what's happening on the ground, but an officer in the helicopter thinks Terrence isn't cooperating. Operator, I think. Moments later, one officer on the ground does fire a taser.
然后他把双手举在空中。片刻之后，他又把手放回了口袋里。此时，多名警察已经聚集起来，拔出了枪和泰瑟枪。头顶上，警用直升机拍摄了事态的发展过程。从视频中很难看出地面上到底发生了什么，但直升机上的一名警察认为特伦斯很不配合。接线员，我认为是这样。片刻之后，地面上的一名警察确实发射了一支泰瑟枪。
Betty Shelby fires her gun. She kills Terence Croucher. Later, police discover that he was unarmed. Soon, accusations are flying. Maybe the victim was high on drugs. Others said maybe the police officer was racist. At a press conference after the shooting, a journalist asked Scott Wood, Betty Shelby's attorney, about that.
贝蒂·谢尔比开枪了。她打死了特伦斯·克劳彻。随后，警方发现他是赤手空拳的。很快，指控纷至沓来。也许受害者吸毒过量。其他人则说也许这个警察是个种族主义者。在枪击事件发生后的新闻发布会上，一名记者向贝蒂·谢尔比的律师斯科特·伍德询问了此事。
Did him being a big black man play a role in her perceived danger? No, him being a large man perceived a role in her being in danger. She's worked in this part of town for quite some time. The week before, she was at an all black high school, homecoming football game. She's not afraid of black people. Terence Croucher's sister Tiffany sees it very differently.
他作为一个身材高大的黑人男子，在她感到的危险中起到了作用吗？没有，他作为一个被认为体型高大的男子，在她感到危险中起到了作用。她在小镇的这个片区工作了相当长一段时间。前一周，她还去了一所全黑人高中的返校节美式橄榄球比赛。她并不害怕黑人。特伦斯·克劳彻的妹妹蒂凡尼有着截然不同的看法。
She thinks her brother was shot because he was black. That big bad dude was my twin brother. That big bad dude was my twin brother. That big bad dude was a father. That big bad dude was a son. That big bad dude was enrolled at Tulsa Community College. Just wanting to make us proud. Betty Shelby's daughter, Amber, defended her mother. I am here to reveal to you the side of my mother
她认为她的兄弟被枪杀是因为他是黑人。那个又高又壮的家伙是我的双胞胎兄弟。那个又高又壮的家伙是我的双胞胎兄弟。那个又高又壮的家伙是一位父亲。那个又高又壮的家伙是一个儿子。那个又高又壮的家伙曾就读于塔尔萨社区学院。只是想让我们感到骄傲。贝蒂·谢尔比的女儿安贝尔为母亲进行了辩护。我来这里是为了向你们展示我母亲的一面
that the public does not know. My mother is an incredible, supportive, loving and caring woman. She is a wife, a mother, and a grand mother, with a heart of gold. She has always fought for the underdog and stands up for the week. And so it went with accusations against and defenses 4, the person who pulled the trigger and the person who got shot. Betty Shelby was recently acquitted of manslaughter charges. Still, the tenor of the back and forth, the psychological accusations and psychological
公众并不了解的一面。我的母亲是一个不可思议的、支持人的、充满爱心和关怀的女性。她是一位妻子、一位母亲、一位拥有金子般心的祖母。她总是为弱势群体战斗，为软弱者挺身而出。针对扣动扳机的人和遭到枪击的人的指控与辩护就这样展开了。贝蒂·谢尔比最近被判过失杀人罪名不成立。尽管如此，这种来回争论的基调、心理上的指控以及心理上的
defenses, it's very revealing. When an incident like this occurs, we want to hear the story of what happened. We want to know what was going on in the mind of the shooter and the mind of the victim. Was Terence Croucher truly a threat? Did Betty Shelby dislike black people? What clues explain the behavior of these individuals? We home in, dig for facts, and look for psychological explanations. But what if there's another way to think about what happened, one that has less to do with the individuals involved, and more to do with the context in which the shooting occurred?
辩护，是非常具有启示意义的。当发生这样的事件时，我们想听听事情经过的故事。我们想知道开枪者和受害者的心中都在想些什么。特伦斯·克劳彻真的构成威胁吗？贝蒂·谢尔比讨厌黑人吗？什么线索能解释这些人的行为？我们深入研究、挖掘事实并寻找心理学解释。但是，如果我们有另一种方式来思考所发生的事情呢？这种方式与涉事个人的关系较小，而与枪击事件发生时的背景关系更大？
What we're discovering here is that the individual mind sits in society, and the connection between mind and society is an extremely important one that should not be forgotten. Individual behavior and the mind of the village this week on Hidden Brain. I'm Maserine Banaji. Maserine is a psychology professor at Harvard. She's made a career out of studying the invisible. For the past 30 years, I've been interested in studying those aspects of our minds that are hidden from our own conscious awareness. Maasareen's interest began in graduate school.
我们在这里发现的是，个人思维植根于社会之中，思维与社会之间的联系极其重要，不容忽视。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨个体行为与群体的思维。我是玛扎琳·巴纳吉。玛扎琳是哈佛大学的心理学教授。她毕生致力于研究无形的事物。在过去的30年里，我一直对研究我们意识中隐藏的那些思维层面感兴趣。玛扎琳的兴趣始于研究生院。
She was teaching psychology at Yale and looking for a way to measure people's biases. There was debate over the right scientific method to do this. You could simply ask people their views, but because prejudice is a sensitive topic, you often don't get anything. You couldn't walk up to somebody and say, do you agree that Italians are lazy and have them say yes or no? They'll just refuse to answer that question. A deep-seated discomfort about discussing prejudice was one hurdle for a researcher
当时她在耶鲁大学教心理学，并寻找一种衡量人们偏见的方法。关于实现这一目标的正确科学方法曾引发过争论。你可以直接询问人们的观点，但由于偏见是一个敏感话题，你往往得不到任何结果。你不能走到某个人面前说：“你同意意大利人很懒吗？”然后让他们回答是或否。他们只会拒绝回答这个问题。对于研究人员来说，对讨论偏见根深蒂固的不适感是一个障碍
looking to study the phenomenon. Maserine realized there was another barrier. What if some forms of prejudice are so deeply buried that people don't even realize they harbor such bias? Perhaps we behave in ways that are not known to our own conscious awareness, that we are being driven to act in certain ways not because we are explicitly prejudiced, but because we make Harry in our heads the thumbprint of the culture. Was there a way to decipher this thumbprint and expose people's hidden biases?
想要研究这一现象的研究人员面临的一个障碍。玛扎琳意识到还有另一个障碍。如果某些形式的偏见埋藏得如此之深，以至于人们甚至没有意识到自己怀有这种偏见呢？也许我们的行为方式连我们自己的意识都不知道，我们之所以会被驱使以某种方式行事，不是因为我们有显性的偏见，而是因为我们在脑海中烙下了文化的指纹。有没有一种方法可以解读这个指纹并暴露出人们隐藏的偏见呢？
Eventually Maserine, with the help of her, Tony Greenwald, and then graduate student, Brian Nosek, developed a simple, ingenious test. It's called the implicit association test or the IAT. It's based on the way we group things in our minds. When you say bread, my mind will easily think butter, but not something unrelated to it. Like say, a hammer. Our brains it turns out make associations and these associations can reveal important things about the way we think.
最终，玛扎琳在托尼·格林沃尔德以及当时的研究生布赖恩·诺塞克的帮助下，开发了一个简单而巧妙的测试。它被称为内隐联结测验，简称IAT。它基于我们在脑海中对事物进行分组的方式。当你提到面包时，我的大脑会很容易联想到黄油，而不会联想到与之无关的东西。比如，一把锤子。事实证明，我们的大脑会建立联结，而这些联结可以揭示关于我们思维方式的重要信息。
So the way the IAT works is to simply ask people to sort things. So imagine that you're given a deck of playing cards and you're asked to sort all the red cards to the left and all the black cards to the right. I'll predict that it will take you about 20 seconds to run through that deck. Next, Mazarin says, shuffle the deck and resort the cards.
因此，IAT的工作原理就是简单地要求人们对事物进行分类。所以想象一下，你拿到了一副扑克牌，要求你把所有的红牌分到左边，把所有的黑牌分到右边。我预测你大概需要20秒钟就能过完这副牌。接着，玛扎琳说，洗牌并重新对牌进行分类。
This time, I'd like you to put all the spades and the diamonds to one side and the clubs and the hearts to the other side. And what we'll find is that this will take you nearly twice as long to do. the diamonds to one side and the clubs and the hearts to the other side. And what we'll find is that this will take you nearly twice as long to do. Why? Because a rule that your brain had learned, red and red go together, black and black go together is no longer available to you.
这一次，我希望你把所有的黑桃和方块放在一边，把梅花和红桃放在另一边。我们会发现，你做这件事所需的时间将近两倍。把方块放在一边，把梅花和红桃放在另一边。我们会发现，你做这件事所需的时间将近两倍。为什么？因为你大脑曾经学过的一个规则——红色与红色归为一组，黑色与黑色归为一组——对你不再适用了。
Remember that in both scenarios, you are grouping two suits together. In the first scenario, you are grouping hearts with diamonds and clubs with spades. In the second scenario, you are grouping hearts with clubs and diamonds with spades. Because there's a simple rule for the first task, group red with red and black with black, that task is easy. In the second scenario, you need a fraction of a second to think about each card. You can't follow a simple rule of thumb. Maserine and Tony and Brian had an important insight. These rules of association apply to many subjects, including the way we think about other human beings.
请记住，在这两种情况下，你都是将两种花色归为一组。在第一种情况下，你将红桃与方块、梅花与黑桃归为一组。在第二种情况下，你将红桃与梅花、方块与黑桃归为一组。由于第一个任务有一个简单的规则，即红色与红色归为一组，黑色与黑色归为一组，因此该任务很容易。在第二种情况下，你每看一张牌都需要零点几秒的时间来思考。你无法遵循一个简单的经验法则。玛扎琳、托尼和布赖恩有一个重要的见解。这些联结规则适用于许多主题，包括我们看待其他人类同胞的方式。
So they created a new sorting task. Sort for me, faces of black people, and bad things together, words like devil and bomb and vomit and awful and failure. Sort those on one side of the playing deck. On the other side, put the faces of white people, and words like love and peace, enjoy and sunshine and friendly and so on to the other side. This turns out to be pretty easy for us to do because as my colleagues and I will argue, the association of white and good and black and bad has been made for us in our culture.
因此，他们创造了一个新的分类任务。为我把黑人的面孔和不好的事物归为一组，比如魔鬼、炸弹、呕吐物、糟糕和失败这些词。把这些放在扑克牌的一侧。在另一侧，放上白人的面孔，以及爱、和平、享受、阳光、友好等词语放在另一侧。事实证明，这对我们来说很容易做到，正如我和我的同事们所争论的那样，在我们的文化中，白人与美好、黑色与糟糕的联结已经为我们做好了。
The test doesn't end there. After sorting white and good into one group and black and bad into another, you now have to do it again, this time grouping black with good and white with bad. And when you try to do that and when I try to do that, the data show that we will slow down, that we can't do it quite as fast because black and good are not practice responses for us. They're not habitual responses for us. We have to exert control to make that happen because it doesn't come naturally and easily to us. That's the IAT.
测试并没有就此结束。在将白色和美好归为一组、黑色和糟糕归为另一组之后，你现在必须再做一次，这次是将黑色与美好归为一组，将白色与糟糕归为一组。当你试图这样做时，当我试图这样做时，数据表明我们会慢下来，我们无法做得那么快，因为黑色和美好对我们来说不是经过练习的反应。它们对我们来说不是习惯性的反应。我们必须施加控制才能让它发生，因为它对我们来说并不是自然而然、轻而易举的。这就是IAT。
By the way, if you're wondering whether the order of the test makes a difference, it doesn't. The researchers have presented tests to volunteers in different ways. It doesn't make a difference if you ask people to first group black with bad or first ask them to group black with good. In both cases, people are faster to associate white faces with positive words and black faces with negative words.
顺便说一句，如果你想知道测试的顺序是否有影响，答案是没有。研究人员以不同的方式向志愿者进行了测试。无论你是先要求人们将黑色与糟糕归为一组，还是先要求他们将黑色与美好归为一组，都没有区别。在这两种情况下，人们都能更快地将白人面孔与积极的词汇联系起来，将黑人面孔与消极的词汇联系起来。
Mazarin thinks the IAT is measuring a form of bias that is implicit or unconscious. Mazarin herself has taken the IAT many times. To her dismay, the test shows she has robust levels of unconscious bias. My brain simply could not make the association of black with good as quickly as I could make the association of white with good. And that told me something, it told me, it's not the IAT that screwed up, it's my head that screwed up. Because the IAT is a timed test, the results can be precisely measured.
玛扎琳认为，IAT正在测量一种隐性的或无意识的偏见形式。玛扎琳本人也多次参加了IAT测试。令她沮丧的是，测试显示她拥有相当程度的无意识偏见。我的大脑无法像将白色与美好联系起来那样迅速地将黑色与美好联系起来。这告诉我一些事情，它告诉我，出问题的不是IAT，而是我的脑袋。由于IAT是一个计时测试，因此可以精确测量结果。
Implicit bias in other words can be quantified. Most psychological tests are only available in the lab, but Mazarin and her colleagues decided to do something radical. They put their test on the internet. You can find it today at implicit.harvard.edu. Millions of people have taken this test. The data has been collected, shared, disseminated. The IAT is widely considered today to be the most influential test of unconscious bias.
换句话说，内隐偏见是可以被量化的。大多数心理学测试只能在实验室里进行，但玛扎琳和她的同事们决定做一件激进的事情。他们把测试搬到了互联网上。你今天可以在 implicit.harvard.edu 上找到它。数百万人参加了这项测试。数据已被收集、分享、传播。今天，IAT被广泛认为是最具影响力的无意识偏见测试。
As Maserine and Tony and Brian were developing the IAT, other researchers were developing different ways to measure bias. Psychologist Joshua Corral found himself diving into the field shortly after a black man was shot and killed in New York City in 1999. His name, Amadou Diallo. Diallo was standing unarmed on the front front stoop of his apartment building in the police thought he looked suspicious and they approached him and they ended up shooting him and the question that everybody was asking and this was I mean something that people you know across
正当玛扎琳、托尼和布赖恩开发IAT时，其他研究人员也在开发测量偏见的不同方法。心理学家约书亚·科雷尔在1999年纽约市一名黑人男子被枪杀后不久，便投身于这一领域的研究。他的名字叫阿马杜·迪亚洛。迪亚洛当时赤手空拳地站在他公寓楼前的前廊上，警察认为他看起来很可疑，于是走近他，最终向他开枪。每个人都在问的问题是——我的意思是，全国各地的人们都在纳闷的事情——他被枪杀是因为他是黑人吗？
the country were wondering about was was he shot because he was black. At the time, Joshua was starting graduate school. I took that question pretty seriously, and we tried to figure out how we could test it in a laboratory. Joshua and his colleagues eventually developed a video game. It was a pretty bad video game, but it did the trick. It's more like a slideshow where there are a series of backgrounds that pop up on the screen, and then in one of those critical backgrounds, a person will suddenly appear. So we've got photographs of, say, 25 or so white men and 25 black men,
当时，约书亚刚开始读研究生。我非常认真地对待这个问题，我们试图找出如何在实验室里对其进行测试的方法。约书亚和他的同事最终开发了一个电子游戏。这是一个相当糟糕的电子游戏，但它确实达到了目的。它更像是一个幻灯片放映，屏幕上会弹出一系列背景，然后其中一个关键背景中会突然出现一个人。所以我们有大约25个白人男性和25个黑人男性的照片，
and we've photographed these guys holding a variety of different objects, cell phones, can of coke, a wallet, a silver pistol, a black pistol. And so we've just edited the photograph so that the person pops up in the background, holding an object, and the player has to decide how to respond. And they're instructed, if the guy on the screen has a gun, he's a bad guy and you're supposed to shoot him. And you're supposed to shoot him. And you're supposed to do that as quickly as you possibly can. What Joshua wanted to know was whether players would respond differently, depending on the race of the target on the screen. Say, a black guy pops up holding a wallet and a white guy pops up holding a wallet.
我们拍下了这些人拿着各种不同物品的照片：手机、一罐可乐、钱包、一把银色手枪、一把黑色手枪。我们只是编辑了照片，让这个人突然出现在背景中，手里拿着一个物品，玩家必须决定如何做出反应。他们的指令是：如果屏幕上的家伙有枪，他就是坏人，你应该射杀他。你应该射杀他。而且你必须以最快的速度完成这件事。约书亚想知道的是，玩家的反应是否会根据屏幕上目标的人种而有所不同。比如，一个黑人手里拿着钱包弹出来，和一个白人手里拿着钱包弹出来。
What's the likelihood that the black guy gets shot and the white guy doesn't? If current events are any clue, you may guess the answer. Here we're looking at, say, you know, the player is responding to a target who's holding a wallet, and the correct decision is to say don't shoot, and what we found is that they are faster to say don't shoot, if the target is white rather than black. The same hell true for arm targets. Test takers were faster to shoot black targets, slower to shoot white ones. Now you might think that Joshua would conclude that his test takers were
黑人被枪杀而白人没有被枪杀的可能性有多大？如果时事能提供任何线索的话，你大概能猜到答案。在这里，我们看到的是，比方说，玩家对一个手里拿着钱包的目标做出反应，正确的决定应该是“不要开枪”，而我们发现，如果目标是白人而不是黑人，他们会更快地做出“不要开枪”的决定。武装目标也是如此。测试者对黑人目标的射击速度更快，对白人目标的射击速度更慢。现在你可能会认为约书亚得出的结论是，他的测试者
just racist, but one important similarity between Joshua's test and Maasareans test is that they do not presume that the people with such biases have active animosity toward African Americans. These are not members of the Ku Klux Klan. It was just exactly what we had predicted and I guess both kind of hoped and animosity toward African Americans. These are not members of the Ku Klux Klan. It was just exactly what we had predicted, and I guess both kind of hoped and feared, right? I mean, it's an exciting scientific moment, but it also suggests something kind of deeply troubling
只是种族主义者，但约书亚的测试和玛扎琳的测试之间的一个重要相似之处在于，他们并不认为带有此类偏见的人对非洲裔美国人抱有积极的敌意。这些人不是三K党成员。这完全正如我们所预测的那样，我想两者既有期待也有对非洲裔美国人的敌意。这些人不是三K党成员。这完全正如我们所预测的那样，我想两者既有期待也有恐惧，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个激动人心的科学时刻，但它也暗示了一些极其令人不安的事情
that these participants who are presumably nice people with no bone to pick, they're not bigots, they're not angry at black people in any way, but what we saw in their data very clearly is an tendency to associate black people with threat and to shoot them more quickly. You can see that both the psychological tests are academic exercises. Do they see anything about how people behave in real life? Joshua Corell is very clear that his video game experiment cannot replicate real life.
这些参与者大概是很好的人，没有什么恩怨要报复，他们不是盲目偏狭的人，他们对黑人没有任何愤怒，但在他们的数据中，我们非常清楚地看到了一种将黑人与威胁联系起来并更快地向他们开枪的倾向。你可以看到，这两个心理学测试都是学术练习。它们能说明人们在现实生活中的行为方式吗？约书亚·科雷尔非常明确地指出，他的电子游戏实验无法复制现实生活。
It's impossible, he says, to recreate in a lab the fear and stress that a real world police confrontation can generate. The IAT2 has been criticized for a somewhat hazy link between test results and real world behavior. Hundreds of studies have been conducted looking at whether the IAT explains or predicts how people will act. The results have been mixed. In some studies, unconscious racial bias on the test seems to predict how people will behave. Researchers found, for example, that doctors who score high and implicit bias are less likely to prescribe clot-pusting
他说，在实验室里重现现实世界中警察对抗可能产生的恐惧和压力是不可能的。IAT也因测试结果与现实世界行为之间有些模糊的联系而受到批评。人们已经进行了数百项研究，以探讨IAT是否能解释或预测人们的行为方式。结果毁誉参半。在某些研究中，测试中的无意识种族偏见似乎确实能预测人们将如何行动。例如，研究人员发现，在内隐偏见测试中得分高的医生，与白人患者相比，不太可能给黑人患者开溶栓心脏药。
heart drugs to black patients compared to white patients. But other studies, also looking at doctors and black and white patients find no correlation between results on the bias test and actual behavior. This discrepancy bothers psychologists to fill Tetlock at the University of Pennsylvania. He is a critic of the IAT. It's a test that is enormously intuitively appealing. I mean, I've never seen a psychological test take off the way the IAT has and it's gripped the popular imagination the way it has, because it just seems on its surface to be measuring something like prejudice.
但其他同样针对医生以及黑人和白人患者的研究发现，偏见测试的结果与实际行为之间没有相关性。这种差异困扰着宾夕法尼亚大学的菲尔·泰特洛克。他是IAT的批评者。这是一个在直觉上极具吸引力的测试。我的意思是，我从未见过哪个心理学测试像IAT那样流行开来，并且以这种方式抓住了大众的想象力，因为它表面上看起来似乎在衡量类似偏见的东西。
Tetlock and other critics are concerned that just because someone shows bias on the IAT doesn't mean that they're going to act in biased ways in real life. If a test cannot predict how you're going to act, isn't it just an academic exercise? There is the question of whether or not people who score as prejudice on the IAT actually act in the discriminatory ways toward other human beings in real world situations. And if they don't, if there is very close to zero relationship between those two things, what exactly is the IAT measuring? It turns out a lot.
泰特洛克和其他批评者担心的是，仅仅因为某人在IAT上表现出偏见，并不意味着他们在现实生活中会以有偏见的方式行事。如果一个测试无法预测你的行为方式，那它不就只是一场学术演习吗？这里存在一个问题：在IAT上被评为有偏见的人，在现实情境中是否真的会对其他人类同胞采取歧视性行为？如果他们没有这样做，如果这两者之间的关系非常接近于零，那么IAT究竟在测量什么？事实证明，测量的内容很多。
There's new evidence that suggests the IAT does in fact predict behavior. But to see it, you have to zoom out. You have to widen the lens to look beyond the individual and into the community. Hello, my name is Eric Haman. He's a psychology professor at Ryerson University. Eric got interested in the IAT as he was researching the use of lethal force in policing. He was trying to design a statistical model that would predict where in the United States people of color are disproportionately likely to be shot and killed by police.
有新的证据表明IAT确实能预测行为。但要看到这一点，你必须把视野拉远。你必须拓宽镜头，超越个体，深入社区。大家好，我是埃里克·海曼。他是瑞尔森大学的心理学教授。埃里克在研究警务工作中致命武力的使用时，对IAT产生了兴趣。他试图设计一个统计模型，以预测美国哪些地方的有色人种更有可能被警察不成比例地枪杀。
First he needed some baseline data. This proved hard since the federal government does not require police departments to report deadly shootings by officers. We really had no idea about really basic questions such as how often they were happening, where they're happening, and who they were happening to. But in 2015 some new outlets, including the Washington Post and the British newspaper the Guardian, began to compile their own database on police homicides in the United States. According to official terminology, these are called justifiable homicides.
首先，他需要一些基准数据。事实证明这很难，因为联邦政府并不要求警察局报告官员的致命枪击事件。对于一些非常基本的问题，我们真的毫无头绪，比如这些事件发生的频率、发生的地点以及受害者是谁。但在2015年，包括《华盛顿报》和英国《卫报》在内的一些新闻机构开始汇编他们自己的美国警察凶杀案数据库。根据官方术语，这些被称为正当杀戮。
So what they were putting together was the most comprehensive list of these justifiable homicides in the United States. Eric used this data to pinpoint where disproportionate police shootings of minorities were most likely. Then he turned to the IAT data. Eric suspected that if bias was a factor in police shootings, it was likely that implicit bias rather than overt racism was at play. Traditionally, the field has found that explicit biases or predict behaviors that are under our conscious control, whereas implicit biases predict things are a little bit more automatic,
因此，他们拼凑出来的是美国这些正当杀戮最全面的清单。埃里克利用这些数据来查明少数族裔更有可能遭到警察过度枪击的地点。然后，他转向了IAT数据。埃里克怀疑，如果偏见是警察枪击事件的一个因素，那么起作用的可能是内隐偏见，而不是公开的种族主义。传统上，该领域发现，显性偏见可以预测那些处于我们意识控制之下的行为，而隐性偏见则可以预测那些更具自动性、
a little bit more difficult to control. And this is exactly this sort of behavior that we thought might be involved in police shootings. People take the IOT anonymously, but they need to provide some information, like their race and where they live. With the millions of data points the IOT provided, Eric painted a map of bias across the United States. Some places seem to have lots of bias. Others very little. Now he had two databases. He cross-reference them to see if there was any connection between communities with disproportionate
更难控制的行为。而这正是我们认为可能卷入警察枪击事件的那种行为。人们匿名参加IAT，但他们需要提供一些信息，比如他们的种族和居住地。凭借IAT提供的数百万个数据点，埃里克绘制了一张全美偏见地图。有些地方似乎有很多偏见。其他地方则非常少。现在他有了两个数据库。他将这些数据库进行交叉比对，以观察少数族裔警察枪击事件不成比例的社区与表现出高水平内隐偏见的社区之间是否存在任何联系。
numbers of police shootings of minorities and communities showing high levels of implicit bias. A powerful correlation emerged. So, we find that in communities in which people have more racial biases, African Americans are being killed more by police than their presence in the population would warrant. Let me repeat this because it's important. In places where implicit bias in a community is higher than average, police shootings of minorities are also higher than average. Erics analysis
一个强烈的相关性浮出水面。因此，我们发现，在人们具有更多种族偏见的社区中，非洲裔美国人被警察杀害的人数超过了他们在人口中所占比例所应有的水平。让我重复一遍，因为这很重要。在社区中内隐偏见高于平均水平的地方，警察对少数族裔的枪击事件也高于平均水平。埃里克的分析
effectively pinpoints where police shootings are likely to happen. But here's what makes the finding crazy. Most people who take the IAT are not police officers. So we're predicting police behavior by not measuring police at all themselves. Coming up, we explore how a test can predict how people will behave, even when they are not the people who take the test. Stay with us. Psychologist Eric Heyman found a way to predict police behavior by comparing places that have high levels of implicit bias with places where police shootings of minorities are higher than average. Since police don't typically take the IAT, how could the IAT be predicting
有效地指出了警察枪击事件可能发生的地点。但这项发现疯狂的地方在于：大多数参加IAT的人并不是警察。因此，我们在根本没有测量警察本身的情况下，通过非警察的数据来预测警察的行为。接下来，我们将探讨一项测试如何能够预测人们的行为，即使他们甚至不是参加测试的人。请继续收听。心理学家埃里克·海曼找到了一种方法，通过将内隐偏见高度集中的地方与少数族裔警察枪击事件高于平均水平的地方进行比较，来预测警察的行为。既然警察通常不参加IAT，IAT怎么能预测
how police would behave? Eric thinks the test has tapped into the mind of the community as a whole. Say there's a neighborhood that's traditionally associated with threat or danger and the people who live in that neighborhood have these associations between African Americans and threat or African Americans and danger. And these would be anybody in this community. This could be my mother or the person who lives down the street, not necessarily the police officers themselves. But there's this idea that this attitude is pervasive across the entire area. And that when officers are operating in that area, they themselves might share that same attitude. That might influence their behaviors in these split-second challenging life and death decisions.
警察的行为会是怎样？埃里克认为，测试已经触及了整个社区的思维。比方说，有一个社区传统上与威胁或危险联系在一起，居住在该社区的人们在非洲裔美国人与威胁之间，或者非洲裔美国人与危险之间建立了这些联结。这些人可以是这个社区里的任何人。这可能是我的母亲或住在街头的那个人，不一定是警察本身。但这有一种观点，即这种态度在整个地区普遍存在。当警官在该地区执勤时，他们自己也可能分享这种态度。这可能会影响他们在这些电光石火、极具挑战性的生死抉择中的行为。
Implicit bias is like the smog that hangs over a community. It becomes the air people breathe. Or as Mazerine might say, the thumbprint of the culture is showing up in the minds of the people living in that community. There are many examples for this idea that individual minds shape the community and the community shapes what happens in individual minds. Set Stevens-Devitovitz is a data scientist who used to work at Google. We featured him on a recent episode of our show. In his book, Everybody Lies, Seth explains how big data from Google searches can predict
内隐偏见就像悬浮在社区之上的雾霾。它成了人们呼吸的空气。或者正如玛扎琳所说的那样，文化的指纹正显现在生活在该社区的人们的头脑中。对于“个体思维塑造社区，而社区又塑造个体思维中发生的事情”这一观点，有很多例子。赛斯·斯蒂芬斯-达维多维茨是一位曾供职于谷歌的数据科学家。我们在节目的近期节目中重点介绍了过他。赛斯在他的著作《人人都在说谎》中解释了谷歌搜索的大数据如何能够以极高的准确率预测
with great accuracy things like the suicide rate in a community or the chances that a hate crime will take place. We've shown that you can predict hate crimes against Muslims based on searches people make. People make very, very, very disturbing searches, searches such as kill Muslims or I hate Muslims. And these searches can predict on a given week how many hate crimes there will be against Muslims. But I think the right
社区中的自杀率或发生仇恨犯罪的可能性等事情。我们已经证明，你可以根据人们的搜索预测针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪。人们会进行非常、非常、非常令人不安的搜索，例如“杀死穆斯林”或“我恨穆斯林”。这些搜索可以预测在特定的一周内会有多少针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪。但我认为正确的方法
approach to this is not to target any particular individual to show up at the door of any particular individual who make these searches. But if there are many, many searches in a given week, it will be wise for police departments to put extra security around mosques because there is greater threat of these attacks. In other words, what the Google search data is doing is effectively taking the temperature of an entire community. That's what you're really saying, that you're picking up on things that are in the ether if you will in the community that might not show up in the individual, but are likely to
不是针对任何特定的个人，去敲任何一个进行这些搜索的特定个人的家门。但是，如果在给定的某一星期内有非常非常多的搜索，警察局明智的做法是在清真寺周围增加安保，因为这些袭击的威胁更大。换句话说，谷歌搜索数据所做的事情，实际上是在为整个社区测量体温。这正是你真正想表达的，你在捕捉社区中那种弥漫在空气中的、可能不会显现在个人身上、但很可能会在总体上显现出来的事物。
show up in the aggregate. Yeah, and I think you don't really know the reason that any particular person makes a search, right? Someone could be searching kill Muslims because they're doing research, or they're just curious about something, or they made a mistake in their typing. There are a lot of reasons that an individual can make these searches.
是的，我认为你确实不知道任何人进行特定搜索的原因，对吧？有人可能会搜索“杀死穆斯林”，因为他们在做研究，或者他们只是对某事好奇，或者他们在打字时犯了个错误。个人进行这些搜索的原因有很多。
But if twice as many people are making these searches, well, if I were a Muslim American, I'd want some extra security around my mosque, right? Asking whether implicit bias affects the behavior of every individual is a little like investigating everyone who types an offensive search term into Google. A lot of the time, you're going to find nothing. And yet, when you look at the use of search terms in aggregate, it can tell you with great precision which areas will see the most hit crimes.
但是，如果有两倍的人在进行这些搜索，好吧，如果我是美国穆斯林，我会在我的清真寺周围加点安保，对吧？询问内隐偏见是否影响每个人的行为，有点像去调查每一个在谷歌上输入攻击性搜索词的人。很多时候，你会发现一无所获。然而，当你从总体上看待搜索词的使用时，它可以极其精确地告诉你哪些地区将看到最多的仇恨犯罪。
For her part, Mazurine Banajiy believes Eric's work is a key link between her psychological data on how individuals behave and sociological insights on how community behaves. What we're discovering here is that the individual mind sits in society and the connection between mind and society is an extremely important one that should not be forgotten and that more than any other group of people, social psychologists, oh it, to the beginnings of their discipline, to do both and to do it even handedly, to be focused on the individual mind and to be talking about how that mind is both
就她而言，玛扎琳·巴纳吉认为埃里克的工作是连接她关于个体行为的心理学数据与关于社区行为的社会学洞察的关键纽带。我们在这里发现的是，个人思维植根于社会之中，思维与社会之间的联系极其重要，不容忽视，并且社会心理学家比其他任何群体的人都更应该将这一理念追溯到他们学科的初期，做到两者兼顾且不偏不倚，既关注个体思维，又探讨这种思维是如何受到其周围更大的社会群体的影响，并反过来影响该群体的。
influenced by and is influencing the larger social group around her. This is why, says Maserine, when a problem has spread throughout a community, when it has become part of the culture, you can't fix it by simply focusing on individuals. One of the difficulties we've had in the past is that we have looked at individual people and blamed individual people. We've said, if we can remove these 10 bad police officers from this force, we'll be fine. And we know our social scientists, and I believe firmly that that is no way to change anything. This new way of thinking about bias showed up in the last presidential election.
这就是为什么，玛扎琳说，当一个问题在整个社区蔓延开来，当它成为文化的一部分时，你不能仅仅通过关注个人来解决它。过去我们遇到的困难之一，就是我们只盯着个人并责备个人。我们曾说：“如果我们能从这支警队中清除这10个坏警察，一切都会好起来的。”我们了解社会科学家，我也坚信这不是改变任何事情的方法。这种思考偏见的新方式出现在上一次总统大选中。
Democrat Hillary Clinton said implicit bias probably played a role in police shootings. I think implicit bias is a problem for everyone, not just police. I think unfortunately too many of us in our great country jumped to conclusions about each other. Republican Mike Pence, now vice president, bristled at the idea. He said that Clinton was calling cops racist. When an African-American police officer is involved
民主党人希拉里·克林顿表示，内隐偏见可能在警察枪击事件中发挥了作用。我认为内隐偏见对每个人来说都是一个问题，不仅仅是警察。我认为不幸的是，我们伟大国家中的太多人对彼此妄下结论。共和党人迈克·彭斯——现任副总统——对这种说法感到愤怒。他说克林顿是在给警察贴上种族主义者的标签。当一名非洲裔美国警察卷入
in a police action shooting involving an African-American, why would Hillary Clinton accuse that African-American police officer of him? I guess I can't believe you are defending a position that there is no bias. But as Maserid says, it's not quite right to think of people with implicit bias I can't believe you are defending a position that there is no bias. But as Mausurine says, it's not quite right to think of people with implicit bias as harboring the kind of racial hostility we typically think of when we say someone is a racist. Small kids show implicit bias. African Americans themselves show implicit bias against other African Americans.
涉及非洲裔美国人的警察执法枪击事件时，希拉里·克林顿为什么要指责那名非洲裔美国警察？我想我简直不敢相信你在为“没有偏见”这种立场辩护。但正如玛扎琳所说，把带有内隐偏见的人视为怀有我们通常在说某人是种族主义者时所想的那种种族敌意，是不大准确的。小孩子也会表现出内隐偏见。非洲裔美国人自己也会对其他非洲裔美国人表现出内隐偏见。
The test isn't picking up the nasty thoughts of a few angry outliers. It's picking up the thumbprint of the culture on each of our minds. So what can we do? Miserine is skeptical of those who offer training courses that promise quick, fixed solutions. There are many people across the country who say that they offer such a thing, called implicit bias training. And what they do is explain to large groups of people what might be going on that's keeping them from reaching their own goals and being the good people that they think they are.
这项测试捕捉到的并不是少数愤怒的极端分子的讨厌想法。它捕捉到的是文化留在我们每个人心智上的指纹。那么我们能做些什么呢？玛扎琳对那些提供承诺快速、固定解决方案的培训课程的人持怀疑态度。全国各地有许多人声称他们提供这种名为“内隐偏见培训”的东西。他们所做的是向一大群人解释可能正在发生的事情，正是这些事情阻碍了他们实现自己的目标，无法成为他们自认为的那种好人。
And my concern is that when I'm an old woman, that I will look back at this time and think, why didn't I do something about this because I don't believe this training is going to do anything? In Mausoleen's view, you can't easily erase implicit bias because you can't erase the effect of the culture when people are living day in and day out in that same culture. But she and others argue that there might be ways to prevent such biases from influencing your behavior.
而我的担忧是，当我成为一个老太太时，我会回首这段时光并想：“我当时为什么不做点什么呢，因为我不相信这种培训会有任何用处？”在玛扎琳看来，你无法轻易消除内隐偏见，因为当人们日复一日地生活在同一种文化中时，你无法消除文化的影响。但她和其他人认为，或许有办法阻止此类偏见影响你的行为。
Let's return to psychologist Joshua Correll. Remember he created the active shooter video game that found test takers were more likely to shoot black targets rather than white ones. Many of Joshua's initial test takers were students. Eventually, he decided to see what would happen if police officers took the test. So he went to the Denver police. We brought down a bunch of laptops and button boxes, a bunch of electronic equipment that we were using to do this study, and we would set it up in their roll call room. And it was just complete chaos and really, really fun. And some of the police really wanted
让我们回到心理学家约书亚·科雷尔。还记得他创造了那个“活跃枪手”电子游戏吗？该游戏发现测试者更有可能射击黑人目标而不是白人目标。约书亚最初的许多测试者都是学生。最终，他决定看看如果警察参加测试会发生什么。于是他去找了丹佛警察局。我们带去了一堆笔记本电脑和按键盒，一堆用于开展这项研究的电子设备，然后我们把它安装在他们的点名室里。那简直是一片混乱，但真的、真的非常有趣。有些警察根本
nothing to do with us, but a huge number of them volunteered and they wanted to talk with us afterwards. At first, the police officers performed exactly the same as everyone else. Their levels of implicit bias were about the same as laypeople who take in the test, both in response times and in mistakes. But when it came to the actual shooting of targets,
不想跟我们扯上关系，但有大量的人自愿参加，而且他们在事起之后还想跟我们交流。起初，警察的表现和其他所有人完全一样。他们的内隐偏见水平与参加测试的普通人差不多，无论是在反应时间还是在错误率上。但当谈到对目标的实际射击时，
the police were very different. The police officers did not show a bias in who they actually shot. Those early test takers, college students and other laypeople displayed their bias on response time, mistakes, and who they shot. Not the police. But whereas those stereotypes may influence the behavior of the college students and of you and me, the police officers are somehow able to exert control. So even though the stereotype, say, of threat may come to mind, the officer can overcome that stereotype and respond based on the information that's actually present in the scene rather than information that the officer is bringing to it through his or her stereotypes.
警察的表现大不相同。警察在究竟射击谁的问题上没有表现出偏见。那些早期的测试者——大学生和其他普通人在反应时间、错误和射击对象上都表现出了他们的偏见。警察则没有。尽管这些刻板印象可能会影响大学生以及你我的行为，但警察不知何故能够施加控制。因此，尽管诸如“威胁”之类的刻板印象可能会浮现在脑海中，但警官可以克服这种刻板印象，并根据现场实际存在的信息做出反应，而不是根据他或她通过刻板印象带入现场的信息。
Joshua wondered whether there were certain factors that might keep police officers from exerting this kind of cognitive control over their biases. He found, among other things, that sleep made a difference. Those who were getting less sleep were more likely to show racial bias in their decisions to shoot. And again, that's just consistent with this idea that they are, they might be able to exert control, to use cognitive resources to avoid showing stereotypic bias in their decisions, but when those resources are compromised, they can't do it. They could be compromised in a variety of ways.
约书亚想知道，是否存在某些因素可能会阻止警察对他们的偏见施加这种认知控制。他发现，除了别的因素之外，睡眠会产生影响。睡眠较少的人在做出开枪决定时更有可能表现出种族偏见。再说一次，这与这种观点完全一致，即他们可能能够施加控制，利用认知资源来避免在决策中表现出刻板印象偏见，但当这些资源受到损害时，他们就无法做到这一点。它们可能会以各种方式受到损害。
Sleep is just one way that we can compromise it. This, once again, is evidence that you can't train people not to have unconscious bias. But as Joshua suggests, you can do things to make it less likely that people will be affected by their bias. To be clear, Joshua's experiments are laboratory experiments. We know in real life that beat police officers do shoot people in error. Now this could be because in a real life encounter, stuff happens that makes it very difficult for you to actually think about what you're doing. So on the street, when somebody pulls a gun on you, it's scary, right? Like, cops when
睡眠只是我们可能会损害这些资源的一种方式。这再次证明了你无法通过训练来教导人们不要产生无意识的偏见。但正如约书亚所建议的那样，你可以采取措施降低人们受其偏见影响的可能性。需要明确的是，约书亚的实验是实验室实验。我们在现实生活中知道，巡警确实会错误地开枪。现在这可能是因为在现实生活中的遭遇中，会发生一些事情，使你很难真正思考自己在做什么。所以在街上，当有人对你拔枪时，那是很可怕的，对吧？比如警察当
they're involved in these fire fights, report some crazy, crazy psychological distortions because they're legitimately freaked out. If they think somebody poses a life and death threat, they may panic, and it may be hard to bring those cognitive resources online. In several recent high profile cases, as with the case of Terence Cratcher and Betty Shelby, police officers shoot people who are unarmed. Of course, officers do not always know whether someone is armed, it's only in hindsight that we know the officer was
他们卷入这些交火时，会报告一些疯狂的、极其严重的心理扭曲，因为他们真的被吓坏了。如果他们认为某人构成了生死威胁，他们可能会惊慌失措，而要让那些认知资源发挥作用可能会变得很困难。在最近几起备受瞩目的案件中，就像特伦斯·克劳彻和贝蒂·谢尔比的案件一样，警察开枪射击了赤手空拳的人。当然，警察并不总是知道某人是否携带武器，只有在事后诸葛亮的情况下，我们才知道警察当时
or wasn't in real danger. Joshua's larger point is that police encounters can be inherently stressful. The uncertainty embedded in a confrontation can make it very difficult to think objectively. To put it another way, if you're running a police department and want to reduce errors and shootings, it may be less useful to give cops a lecture on how they shouldn't be racist and more useful to build procedures that give cops an extra half-second when they are making decisions under pressure. With practice and a bit of time to exercise conscious control, people can reduce the risk of falling prey
是否真的处于危险之中。约书亚更广泛的观点是，警察的遭遇本质上可能会充满压力。对峙中固有的不确定性会使客观思考变得极其困难。换句话说，如果你在管理一个警察局并希望减少错误和枪击事件，那么给警察作关于他们不应该有种族主义倾向的讲座可能用处不大，而建立一些程序，在警察承受压力做决策时给他们额外的半秒钟时间，可能会更有用。通过练习和一点时间来行使有意识的控制，人们可以降低沦为牺牲品的风险
to their implicit biases. There is the potential to control it, right? The performance of the regular police officers, or even people that we train in our lab, suggests that people don't have to succumb to those stereotypic influences. They can exert control in certain circumstances. Maserine Banaji has a similar solution. She thinks we need more of what she calls in the moment reminders.
针对他们的内隐偏见。这其实是有可能控制的，对吧？普通警察的表现，甚至我们在实验室里训练的人的表现，都表明人们不必屈服于那些刻板印象的影响。他们在某些情况下是可以进行控制的。玛扎琳·巴纳吉（Mahzarin Banaji）也有类似的解决方案。她认为我们需要更多她所说的“即时提醒”。
For example, it's been found that some doctors prescribe painkillers to white patients far more often than they do to black patients who are reporting exactly the same levels of pain. The only difference is the patient's skin color. This suggests that bias is at work. Maserine says if the bias is implicit, meaning physicians are acting biased without intending to be biased, a timely reminder can help doctors exercise cognitive control over their unconscious associations. You type in a painkiller that you want to prescribe to a patient into your electronic system while the patient is sitting next to you.
例如，人们发现有些医生给白人患者开止痛药的频率，远高于给那些报告疼痛程度完全相同的黑人患者开药的频率。唯一的区别就是患者的肤色。这表明偏见正在起作用。玛扎琳说，如果这种偏见是内隐的，也就是说医生在没有主观恶意的情况下表现出了偏见，那么及时的提醒可以帮助医生对他们的无意识联想进行认知控制。当患者坐在你身边时，你在电子系统中输入你想给患者开的止痛药。
And it seems to me quite simple that when you type in the name of any painkiller, let's say, Codine, that a little graph pops up in front of you that says, please note, in our hospital system, we have noticed that this is the average amount of painkiller we give to white men. This is the average amount we give to black men for the same reported level of pain. In other words, giving doctors an opportunity
在我看来，这其实很简单：当你输入任何止痛药的名字，比如可待因（Codine），你的面前就会弹出一个小图表，上面写着：“请注意，在我们的医院系统中，我们注意到这是我们给白人男性的平均止痛药剂量。这是我们给因相同疼痛程度报告的黑人男性的平均剂量。”换句话说，就是给医生提供一个机会
to stop for a second to make a decision consciously and deliberately, instead of quickly and automatically, this can reduce the effects of implicit bias. Psychology has spent many years understanding the behavior of individuals, but tools such as the IAT might give us away to understand communities as a whole, maybe even countries as a whole.
停顿一秒钟，有意识、审慎地做出决定，而不是仓促、自动地做出决定，这可以减少内隐偏见的影响。心理学花了很多年时间来了解个体的行为，但诸如内隐联想测验（IAT）之类的工具可能会为我们提供一种方法，来了解整个社区，甚至可能是整个国家。
We did a study some years ago, Brian Nosek led this particular project in which we looked at gender stereotypes across many countries in the world, how strongly do we associate female with science and male with science. And then we looked at the performance of girls and boys, roughly around eighth grade, on some kind of a standardized test. And what we discovered is that the stronger the gender bias in a country, that is to say the stronger the association of male with science in a country, the less well girls in that country did on that mathematics test. It's very similar to the Haman kind of result because we didn't measure the gender bias in the girls and the boys who took the test. We were measuring something at the level of a country
我们几年前做过一项研究，布莱恩·诺塞克（Brian Nosek）领导了这个特定项目，我们在其中研究了世界上许多国家的性别刻板印象，即我们将女性与科学、男性与科学联系在一起的强度有多大。然后，我们研究了大约八年级的女孩和男孩在某种标准化测试中的表现。我们发现，一个国家的性别偏见越强，也就是说，一个该国将男性与科学联系在一起的倾向越强，该国女孩在那场数学测试中的表现就越差。这与哈曼（Heilman）的研究结果非常相似，因为我们并没有测量参加测试的女孩和男孩的性别偏见。我们衡量的是国家层面的某些东西
in that case. And yet it did predict something systematic about the difference in performance between boys and girls. When we look at an event like a police shooting, we invariably seek to understand it at the level of individuals. If something bad happens, we think it has to be because someone had bad intentions. Implicit bias certainly does act on individuals, but it's possible that its strongest effects are at the level of a community as a whole. This might be why some police shootings of African-American men are carried out by African-American police officers,
在这种情况下。然而，它确实预测了男孩和女孩之间表现差异的一些系统性规律。当我们看到像警察枪击这样的事件时，我们总是试图从个体层面去理解它。如果发生了不好的事情，我们就会认为这一定是因为某人有不良动机。内隐偏见确实会对个人产生影响，但它最强烈的影响可能是在整个社区的层面。这或许就是为什么一些针对非裔美国男性的警察枪击事件是由非裔美国警察执行的，
and why some physicians who are not prescribing pain medications to people of color might themselves be people of color. Individuals can do their part to limit the effects of bias on their behavior, but if you want to fix the bias itself, well, that takes the whole village. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Peneman and Raina
以及为什么一些不给有色人种开止痛药的医生本身可能也是有色人种。个人可以尽自己的一份力量来限制偏见对其行为的影响，但如果你想彻底消除偏见本身，那就需要整个村庄（全社会的共同努力）。本期《Hidden Brain》由珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、玛吉·佩内曼（Maggie Peneman）和雷娜
Cohen. It was edited by Tara Boyle. The music in today's show was composed by Ramteen Arablui. René Clar does our social media. This week our unsung hero is Izzy Smith. He directs the promotion of NPR's podcasts and works tirelessly to get the content we're making to reach new ears. If you ever discovered a new favorite show because it was recommended by another podcast you love, you have Izzy to thank. Izzy recently led the TriPod initiative that encouraged all of you to share the podcast
科恩（Cohen）制作。本期节目由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。今天节目的音乐由拉姆廷·阿拉布鲁伊（Ramteen Arabloui）创作。勒内·克拉尔（René Clar）负责我们的社交媒体。本周我们的幕后英雄是伊兹·史密斯（Izzy Smith）。他负责指导NPR播客的推广，并不知疲倦地工作，让我们的内容触及更多新的听众。如果你曾经因为你喜欢的另一个播客的推荐而发现了一个新的最爱节目，那么你得感谢伊兹。伊兹最近领导了“TriPod”倡议，鼓励大家分享播客
you listened to on social media and though that campaign is technically over, it's never too late to tell a friend about Hidden Brain. You can find us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen for my stories each week on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. Hey Podcast listeners, a couple of things before we go. If you enjoyed this show on implicit bias and the IAT, make sure you check out the June 15th episode of Invisibilia, which looks at where our bias has come from and whether we can do anything about them. The show visits a group of people in a new program
你在社交媒体上收听的内容，尽管该活动在技术上已经结束，但向朋友推荐《Hidden Brain》永远不会太迟。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上找到我们，每周还可以在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆（Shankar Vedantam），这是NPR。嘿，播客听众们，在我们离开之前还有几件事。如果你喜欢这期关于内隐偏普及IAT的节目，请务必查看6月15日的《Invisibilia》，该节目探讨了我们的偏见从何而来以及我们是否能对此做些什么。该节目拜访了一群来自一个新项目的人
in California called Racist Anonymous, talks to scientists who are exploring concrete ways to counter prejudice and writes along with a Ferguson police officer who's grappling with his own experiences as a victim and a perpetrator of bias. Finally, we're working on a show about regrets. If you have a funny story or a not-so-funny story about something you regret and you're willing to talk about it, please give us a call and tell us your story. Leave a message at 661-772-7246. That's 661-772-brain. You can also record a voice memo and email it to us at hiddenbrainatnpr.org. Please put the word regret in the subject line. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州的一个名为“种族主义者匿名”（Racist Anonymous）的项目，与正在探索对抗偏见的具体方法的科学家进行了交谈，并与一名弗格森警察一起记录了他在处理自己作为偏见受害者和施暴者的经历。最后，我们正在制作一期关于后悔的节目。如果你有一个有趣的故事或不太有趣的故事，关于你后悔的事情，并且你愿意谈论它，请给我们打电话并告诉我们你的故事。请在661-772-7246留言。也就是661-772-brain。你也可以录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们：hiddenbrain@npr.org。请在主题行中输入单词“regret”（后悔）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。